the Joe Rogan experience so much of this
technology is cheap now to get so even
if if you were to show up with with two
thousand dollars worth of equipment you
could see if there was some scientific
basis to what these people are doing but
from my understanding I didn't go down
to the Chi hole to too deep but a lot of
these people aren't showing up and and
offering volunteering to have their
skills
you know tested and and that's how
science works you have to test it right
it has to be replicable
well it's everybody wants to be Swami
Rama but nobody wants to do what Swami
Rama did right yeah who wants to sit in
a kit well some people do sit in a cave
for 30 years right he would go way for
it for years at a time in a dark cave
and just sit there and breathe so I just
in the modern age I just don't know god
I would love to talk to him yeah he had
it all down because there are people
that can do that you know they're like
the Unabomber of breathing you know they
just move to the woods and just just
without the negativity but but what was
what was cool about him is he wasn't the
only one who could do this so there were
researchers in the 20s and in the 40s
who went out with a bunch of equipment
whatever equipment they could cobble
together and tested other Yogi's who
were able to do this exact same thing
right so so Swami was part of this long
lineage of people who had this knowledge
is it still there it could be but again
I don't think it's online I think you
really have to get out in the weeds and
and earn these people's trust in order
to get that story and what is what what
is the history of these people doing
this like what was their initial
motivation I mean is there a written
history of this the earliest evidence
that we have for breathing practices
dates back about 4000 or 5000 years from
these little statuettes in the Indus
Valley which is in northern India so
there was this huge thriving
civilization they had paved roads they
had running water they were dealing with
tin and copper and they had no in this
in this whole civilization they still
have not found any political or
governmental buildings they haven't
found any religious I cannot
Rafi so these people in some ways could
have been more more advanced than we are
now
and they had all of these figures of
these people in these these yoga poses
with their stomachs out so that's how
they date the earliest archaeological
evidence of that and since then then all
of these practices were moved into the
Rig Veda and and all of the earliest
yoga texts and they were codified in the
Yoga Sutras of Patanjali
is that's where a lot of the yoga
methods come from and that's about 2,000
years old so the methods predate all
that oh I'm sure they predate probably
anything that that has been in writing
wouldn't that's what's so curious to me
what makes me so curious if you really
think about what life must have been
like back then the when they were
creating this you would think that
people were hunting and gathering it was
probably a very hard life well not not
in that civilization right it got to a
point where they had some sort of
agriculture or some some structures and
buildings but how did they get to the
point where because the rest of the
world didn't obviously didn't do this
this is not like common practice in
Germany or in Italy or in all these
other civilizations like what made these
people focus on breath works a month
well it could have been but we just
haven't found anything related to that
yet right so if you think about
hunter-gatherers we're imagining them as
man they're just working all day they're
hunting all day they're gathering that
they weren't from from what I know and
from what I've seen of the science
they're the probably three or four hours
of work you know and then you have no
other distractions to spend time and and
build these systems of breathing and
health which is what started in in
ancient China which is what started in
India which is what started in ancient
Greece think about all the distractions
we're dealing with today constant
interruptions if you've already done
your work for the day
there's nothing else to do you're gonna
get more interesting you're gonna have
the time to do some empirical studies to
to see what works and what doesn't it
just seems to me that like learning
something like that learning something
like
long breath work and the benefits of it
I mean it seems like this is a really
long-term practice it doesn't show you
immediate benefits yes and no I I think
that you can take someone who has a
serious problem maybe someone who's
already very fit it's gonna take a while
to really see those big benefits we see
that with athletes with nasal breathing
take some weeks or sometimes months to
really see gains and performance but if
you've got someone with a chronic
condition like asthma or anxiety who are
struggling to breathe every single day
and you teach them some basic breathing
some normal breathing patterns their
lives can be absolutely transformed and
we've seen this in study after study so
these people their breathing has become
so disrupted their breathing's in such
an unhealthy way that they don't know
what proper breathing is and just
shifting that has a tremendous impact
[Applause]